organizers of a free speech rally today
in Boston are distancing themselves from
the racist groups that demonstrated in
charlottesville counter demonstrators
are expected to intend hundreds of
police officers will be deployed to
deter violence the rally will be held at
the nation's oldest city park Boston
Common DeMarco Morgan is there DeMarco
good morning good morning Anthony the
so-called free speech rally starts at
noon not far from where we are standing
and thousands of protesters are expected
to attend and you mentioned an officers
say they are ready and they are prepared
they have designated areas for both
groups the alt-right and white
supremacists will be in one area and the
counter protesters will be in another
this is all in an effort to prevent what
happened in Charlottesville Virginia
now Boston's Police Commissioner has two
pointers of security cameras and they
have a list of prohibited items pretty
much any and everything that could be
used as a weapon
they are planned speakers again for
today's event that are sure to promote
one crowd of protesters and provoked the
other we got a chance to speak with the
organizer up today's event being put on
by the Boston Free Speech Coalition John
meddler a 23 year old student at
Pittsburg State College now he
understands that white supremacist
groups are planning to attend today's
event and rally behind his organization
but he told us he will not tolerate hate
speech reasonable people on both sides
who are taught who are tolerant enough
to not resort to violence when they hear
something that they disagree with
reasonable people who are willing to
actually listening to each other need to
come together and start promoting that
instead of letting the alt Bowl all of
these fringe groups on the left and the
right determine what we can and cannot
say you can tell that the roads are
pretty much open right here behind me
but they will be closed off when the
rally starts or I should say an hour to
before the rally starts in an effort
again to prevent
happened in Charlottesville the rally
starts today at 12 noon well some things
back to you
DeMarco Morgan in Boston DeMarco thank
you